welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder revealed
a new look at valkyrie seated beside the
mighty thor jane foster and before we
even have a second to wish we could be
one of those grapes boss damn it who is
that in the lower right hand corner that
is actor akosia sabit in the role imdb
is calling bastet god which might also
be the wakandan panther goddess of bost
her headpiece has feline ears oh my god
folks in one shot marvel studios may
have just linked three corners of its
universe thor black panther and moon
knight maybe even eternals as well we'll
see if they just want us to forget that
happened bost of wakanda is derided from
the real world egyptian feline deity of
bostit bastet is often associated with
segment segment being the warrior bost
or bastet they go by both names being
the gentler figure of the two now
wakandan mythology in the marvel comics
and it's depicted in the 2018 black
panther film is a fictional religion
inspired from a confluence of cultures
across the african continent moon knight
explored how egyptian gods from our
history exist within the mcu and ones
like tower x khonshu and ahmet take an
animalistic form as they do in egyptian
art and possess humans as their avatars
bastet appeared among the egyptian
iconography and moon knight in the gift
shop beside donna in episode 1 and a
statue of bastet appeared among makari's
collections in eternals so she is part
of all of this help marvel studios may
even say that the way moon knight
superpowers come from him being the
avatar of konchu the black panther is
the avatar of bost moon knight episode 5
had an awesome moment where tuaret the
hippopotamus goddess of fertility and
protection name-dropped the wakandan
ancestral plane from black panther this
is the afterlife the afterlife
you'd be surprised how many
intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist yeah ah like the
ancestral plane oh just gorgeous because
the jew arts true nature is impossible
for the human mind to comprehend all
right you may perceive this realm as
something more easily recognizable to
you so the fact that bastet or bost now
shows up in thor 11 thunder in this form
tells us a lot about how marvel studios
wants us to see how the gods and
goddesses of all these titles are
connected so let's break down what she
is doing here her relationship with
valkyrie and jane and how she will
respond to what we think gore the god
but sure will do to all the gods of this
film and don't worry i think pasta is
gonna be okay so tuara it's line about
the ancestral plain indicates that all
the afterlives of the mcu are part of
the same plane of existence they just
take different appearances to whomever
occupies them for mark specter and
steven grant they have been the avatar
of the egyptian deity of khanshu making
them devout followers of that belief
system and as such the underworld to
them is the egyptian duat also a psych
ward of a hospital because they are
going through dissociative identity
disorder for t'challa he was raised
worshipping bost as we heard in his line
in civil war in my culture
dead
it's not the end
it's marve
stepping off point
you reach out with both hands and bust
in sekhmet
they lead you into the green world where
you can run forever and so for t'challa
and his ancestors the afterlife took the
form of the ancestral plane it's
interesting how for killmonger that
afterlife took the form of his father's
oakland apartment now it's interesting
that t'challa mentioned both bost and
segment implying that they are partners
and we might see both of them at some
point in the mcu and his phrasing sounds
a lot like tuareg leading souls through
the duat to the aru the field of reads
where they could presumably run forever
this whole belief-centered approach is
actually how the asgardians like thor
and valkyrie were redefined in more
recent marvel comics as
extraterrestrials in a specific stage of
their celestial mutation cycle that
their physical appearances and their
powers take the form of the inner
beliefs of the lowered lifeforms that
they protect so since the norse people
of 965 a.d believed in viking kings
being their saviors that's the form odin
takes now i don't know how specific
marvel films and series we'll get with
codifying these terms i'm just saying
that a logical framework exists in the
comics now thor love and thunder is
changing the mythological game by
introducing us to the greek and the
roman gods of the mcu who reside in
olympus these include zeus but will also
likely include ares and hercules maybe
athena which would present a bit of a
logical issue with the eternals who were
said to be the origins of our real world
mythologies like athena being inspired
by athena etc but the eternal film also
established that those beings were all
synthetic drones designed by the
celestials to caretake planets until
those planets were destroyed and none of
those eternals were actually unique so
they might have actually just gotten
their names from actual cosmic deities
who reside in olympus and i have
theorized in the past how gore's anger
at all these guys might be due to a
corrupt bargain between the celestials
and these other gods of olympus now when
i broke down the thor love and thunder
trailer i pointed out how that shot of
zeus presiding over the pantheon of gods
includes rows of seats arranged in a
kind of arena with box sections each
section having its own larger figures
surrounded by smaller peripheral figures
who each get their own seats and the
seats that jane and valkyrie and bastet
now sit in look a lot like that same
seating arrangement that bowl of grapes
is the same kind of decadence that seems
to run throughout olympus at zeus's side
and the opulent walkways that they
stroll but this video is brought to you
by the ridge the ridge wallet is light
sleek and industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky monstrosities that make a sit
crooked when they're in our back pockets
the ridge comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash so you can show
up your fancy euro collection to
cashiers and other people who probably
don't care every ridge wallet comes with
a lifetime guarantee and they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and send it
back for a full refund if you don't love
it they also have great backpacks phone
cases and other cool gear so get 10 off
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to ridge.com new
rockstars that's ridge.com new rockstars
and use code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description so the fact
that these three are seated here tells
us a lot because it means that asgard
and the gods assigned to midgard aka
earth are part of a larger hierarchy of
mcu gods where they all have seats as
part of a representative congress at
olympus where zeus presides now what
that means zeus outranked odin i don't
know maybe valkyrie just doesn't yet
have the seniority odin had now we
should say we do not yet know if marvel
studios is saying for sure that bastet
and bost are the same figure within this
hierarchy of gods or if they're actually
two separate figures like the egyptians
had their mythology the wakandans of
their mythology and there may have just
been some cross-pollination for which
culture influenced the other but they
just ended up calling the two different
gods by similar sounding names but it is
important to note that in the chronology
established by the mcu the warrior
bashanga first consumed that
heart-shaped herb met bost and united
the tribes of wakanda in the year 10 000
bc that would be long before the ancient
egyptians were around also long before
the ancient civilization that predated
the egyptians to sumerians which was the
group the eternals made contact with in
this movie's prologue so really
according to the mcu wakanda and their
religious beliefs were the first ones
that arose on earth and would have
inspired the others the wakandan boss
inspiring the egyptian bastet not the
other way around but it is also totally
plausible for boston bostet to just be
defined as the same figure like the
egyptians could have heard about bost
and given her her own similar identity
within their mythology maybe boss even
used to hang out with indiana as bostet
and then just parted ways because they
suck but bost or bastet why does she
take a human form here well she may only
take the form of a giant panther to the
mortals of earth whereas here she takes
on a more practical form we may even
learn that olympus could be part of the
overvoid where those five members of the
inead and moon knight retreated to so
what is happening here i think all of
these gods representing the diversity of
faces across planets are being summoned
back to olympus in this congress with
zeus to respond to a crisis gods are
being slaughtered and valkyrie now ruler
of asgard and jane now the bearer of
mjolnir are among these representatives
as is bastet maybe also the members of
the inead maybe the deity worshiped by
the centaurian tribes that's the race of
yondu who also appears in this trailer
footage but i also think this gathering
is exactly what gore the god butcher
actually wants so that he can
assassinate as many of them as possible
in one strike now i do not think that
all the gods will die but several of
them probably will and i'm sure it's
gonna be pretty fun but while i think
the senior gods are gonna be the bigger
targets they're literally looming large
as bull's-eyes in each box there i think
the lesser gods will have a better
chance of escaping so like hercules a
marvel hero many want to see in an
active role in the mcu technically the
half mortal son of zeus i hope he
escapes and of course bost or bastet
especially in her less assuming human
form might be less of a target but
there's also gonna be an opportunity to
show how much of a badass warrior boss
is or her partner segment is how they
can fend off gore's assault proving that
the black panther's strength comes from
a goddess protecting her people on
fronts they are not even aware of
because folks i don't think the mcu is
going to eliminate bost from this
universe ahead of black panther wakanda
forever really i think she appears here
to suggest that the people of wakanda
are part of the same hierarchy as the
asgardians the eternals and moon knight
and this is exactly the cross title
organization this scattered phase four
universe really needs you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow me rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you